- America.
Land of the free, home of the brave.
You've got some great
things like barbecue,
baseball, a hip president,
but here are some things
you're doing bloody wrong.
(classical music)
Roundabouts.
You just don't have enough of them.
Wouldn't you rather deal with this
than this?
Food.
American pancakes.
Fluffy, delicious but incredibly wrong.
These are pancakes.
They are made in a pan.
We even have a whole day for them.
Also, your flapjacks are not flapjacks.
These are flapjacks.
Think of a better version
of the granola bar.
Actually, you're doing
a lot of foods wrong.
Toast, chips, crisps, bangers.
Pleasantries.
You're wasting far too much
time when talking to friends.
For instance, you see
a mate on the street,
you go, "All right?" and
they say, "All right?"
Conversation over.
It's great, isn't it?
Instead of listening 20 reasons
why you can't do something,
just say to your mate,
"I can't be bothered."
See? Easier.
Slang.
Your slang is quite boring and
not nearly confusing enough
so allow me to kindly explain
using a recent phrase.
So what is a nandos
and why is it so cheeky?
So you're with the lads after a night out
and you're all like,
"Let's go at Mackey-D's,"
but your other mate is like,
"Nah, let's go at chicken nandos instead."
Everyone is like, "Brilliant,"
so you go have chicken nandos
and a bit of topnotch
banger with the lads.
Still confused?
It's like, say, one night
you're out with your bros
and you think, "Let's go to MacDonalds."
Where your friends are like,
"No dude, got to step it up a notch.
"Let's go at IHOP."
You have a great time and
you all go home happy.
Make sense?
Great.
What other things are
Americans doing wrong?
(classical music)